aujourd'hui tu vas manger sain et
équilibré
après avoir déposé la gosse tu haïras
ton cours de danse classique je passerai
une bonne journée jury au café
équilibré 3 cheeseburger signature 3
grande frite et un milkshake au chocolat
après avoir dépoussiéré gosse
j'irai à mon cours de danse classique
peur bleue et passera une bonne journée
le professeur robin va se faire virer
on aura besoin de pognon point g tm peu
importe ce qui se passe tu penses que ça
va mal se passer non tu a confié ta vie
est ce blaireau
la
savane sommes désolés
vous n'êtes pas à 100 cela et voilà
bravo elle voit que t'es qu'une possible
commune
je m'étais pas senti aussi bien depuis
très longtemps
tu veux je prends des cours d'aérobic et
tu lis ça pourrait vous plaire des
premiers cours tu sens déjà changement
ton corps reprend le contrôle combien de
temps on va pouvoir vivre sur nos
économies on doit tous participé et
candy dit on ça veut dire toi t'as
jamais pensé engagé un de profs c'est
qu'une fois encore je veux pouvoir
j'espère oxydé à droite désolé pour
voter à gauche
ça arriverait pas à suivre fondre dans
le décor ce qu'on pense que vous
ressentez je pourrais venir chez vous
vous donner un cours privé il ya une
petite chance pour que ce soit pas une
idée nul côté free
[Musique]
c'est pas de quoi je suis capable
vous allez construire quelque chose
quelque chose de solide et qui est
seulement à trois cordes et personne ne
nous l'enlèvera
je ne sous estime pas
[Musique]
on va leur en mettre plein la vue
champions
[Musique]